so it's December and I started thinking
to myself what kind of videos can I do
this month something wholesome nice and
christmas-related
then the more I thought about it I'm
doing a lot of Christmas videos this one
as I do every month and for whatever
reason I started thinking about the
Disney films you know the ones that we
all the more I was thinking about it
there wholesome all the time they don't
wait one month a year to shine all the
magic and goodness of humanity on us
they have to be whimsical all year round
and that can't be easy
so I decided screw it I'm just gonna
review all the Disney films that is to
say all the animated 2d Disney films
with some exceptions why because I love
Disney and so do you oh you may act like
you don't like Disney you may talk about
how it's an evil corporate monster that
only gets stronger and stronger the
longer we live but the funny thing is
you don't have a choice you can bombard
us with all the genius monstrous things
that Disney has done in the past
you can argue debatable messages you can
argue debatable ethics you can even
argue debatable stereotypes but it
doesn't matter
Disney has always been there for most of
us it's the first thing we're introduced
to and that's the genius of Disney
putting all the time and all their
effort not in something adult but in
something for children and once
something has your childhood by the
balls it's never gonna leave you it's
there forever
Disney has practically become family to
us it's fairy tales it's magic it's
everything that we enjoyed and thought
was possible when we were younger and as
we for older there's all of other things
to enjoy the artistry the creativity the
imagination there's literally no other
word for it but Disney it's an artistic
cultural phenomenon that will never ever
leave now I'm just gonna state upfront
that I am directly ripping off
cinemassacre x' monster bands
we're james rolfe reviews a new monster
movie every day of october i think it's
a cool idea and i want to do it what
something I really enjoyed the
hand-drawn animated Disney movies the
only downside is there's only so many
days in December and there's just a
friggin boat load of beets boobies so
I'm probably gonna do about three a day
and once or twice that may skip over but
I'll do my best to comment on as many as
possible and keep in mind this is just
my own personal pick if you like or hate
any of these films there's nothing wrong
with them I'm just putting out though
what I think of some of the most beloved
classics of all time so sit back and
enjoy the month of what I like to call
Disney 7
let's start off with the very first
animated film ever made Snow White and
the Seven Dwarves we often associate the
Disney formula with a princess and a big
castle in some sort of far-off fairy
tale and even though not all the films
are like that in fact probably not even
the majority that's the one kids seem to
like the most and it started at the very
beginning Disney knew then that the more
timeless you can make something the
longer it'll be around so logically it
makes sense to start off with a fairy
tale and as the first film goes it's
pretty damn impressive I mean okay it's
not entirely timeless I mean the designs
are kind of 40s some of the characters
aren't as developed as children's films
are today it's Snow White singing voices
very bitty bitch to describe the story
is almost silly we all know it an evil
queen wants to be the quote-unquote
fairest of them all but finds out that
there's only one young woman in her way
the princess Snow White so she sends a
hunter out to kill her but the hunter is
just so blown away by how hot she is he
can't do it so he tells her to run away
and she comes across a cottage filled
with Seven Dwarves which for me as a kid
always raised a lot of questions are the
dwarves related are they brothers did
they all just meet at random if so is
there a place where dwarves just usually
meet well I'm overanalyzing the Queen
finds out that Snow White is still alive
and puts on a disguise to try and kill
her kind of Dreams if you wouldn't just
send a henchman or somebody else to do
it they definitely have just the one but
again over analyzing the film is about
as basic children's movie as you can get
is very bright it's very colorful but it
doesn't try to insult the audience
intelligence either as Disney Princesses
go Snow White is probably one of the
weaker ones as she is sort of just bland
and general and ice but on the upside
she is generally nice there's nothing
really wrong with her she's just not
particularly interesting to be fair
though she's a lot more engaging than
the prince who only gets about three
lines and most of them are just some the
dwarfs of course is what everybody
remembers the different personalities
the different ways they're drawn the
fact that their emotional status also
happens to be their names that's what
the kids enjoy adults can enjoy the
artistry a little bit
not just the bright colors a pretty
background but also some of the scary
images they have well the story itself
is not especially dark it was pretty
ballsy to throw in some of this really
creepy imagery the queen is a villain
when you really analyze it is a pretty
boring villain she doesn't say much she
doesn't do much just a really vain woman
there's nothing really that fascinating
in the kids film but what keeps her
pretty enjoyable again is the animation
she's just drawing great I mean she has
this permanent frown on her face I'm
trying to think if I ever saw her smile
in the film and of course the design of
her after the transformation is just
awesome he used to scare the crap
underneath when I was a kid but in
general does Snow White hold up as a
film even if you emotionally
disconnected from the fact that you saw
when you were a child
well the key word there is emotion much
like The Wizard of Oz or even where the
wild things are this is a film that is
entirely fueled on emotion logic plays
very little part in it and to be honest
I find films like that very fascinating
they don't give you what you logically
are ethically want to see they give you
what your emotions want to see like the
prince comes kisses her and they ride
off into the castle well okay how did he
find her where did he come from
did they ever have a conversation in the
movie doesn't make sense that they would
ride off together of course not but
that's not what your emotions want to
see they want to see the happiest of
endings after the saddest and darkest of
moments oh yeah don't think this scene
didn't me up you can keep ambe's
mom you can keep Simba's dad this is the
scene that rips me to shreds why because
it's like a wake literally down to the
oregon music how much more depressing
can you get the dwarves aren't just
trying
they are sobbing bawling over the fact
that they've lost the only woman that's
ever come into their lives
so of course as a young boy I'm sitting
there thinking up it's just a
cartoon ain't gonna leave an impact on
me oh no not grumpy not grumpy no he was
the tough one
just let your throne right now there's
no purpose in living but that's just how
the film works it did well to help kids
emotionally connect with things that we
weren't often used to connecting with
ensure she comes back to life they live
happily ever have
but we didn't know that even if we did
this is still a pretty sad thing to go
through for a little kid this is pretty
heavy so apart from it just being ground
breaking as the first animated film I
think actually it does hold up for
little kids and I've even argue adults
is it complex no is it engaging no but
it's emotional simplicity does manage to
tap into the audience to a point where
we're not even questioning the obvious
logical problems they're just staring us
in the face creating a world for us
we're happily ever after it's okay to
believe
[Music]
you